foreign
[Music]
so in the field where the plane went
down they're building a memorial
and the memorial was uh first shown in
2006 and it was outrageous it was a
large red Islamic Crescent yes yeah
placing Mecca facing Mecca and in the
blocks for the people yes like with the
star and the blocks including the blocks
that was for each of the victims also
were the Muslim terrorists they got a
block too isn't that nice yeah so there
was a big on the net okay and the
difference between this and the ground
zero mask is that it made the big leap
from the internet
uh it didn't make the leap I should say
that the ground zero mask made from the
internet to the National Consciousness
um they did change it
they did it with such a uproar on the
net and Alec Royal was really
instrumental in getting a change they
did change it but it is when you go home
Google Islamic
that's into my category Flight 93
Memorial y93 Islamic world and you will
see what it looks like and you make your
own determination
um it seems these these committees that
they that they form even in the ground
zero mosque the memorial I mean Daisy
Cod is sitting on the 911 museum and
Memorial and let me tell you something
as egregious as the Islamic
Crescent is right
they say it's not they say it's not and
you're seeing things I love it you know
spin my face
it's not it's not the ground zero mob
but if you look at what they're doing
down in ground zero the memorial it's
outrageous that first of all it's seven
stories under it's like a coffin that
they had to fight I mean many of the
families that are here slept outside
because in the memorial you know the the
waterfalls the names of the loved ones I
mean frankly I'd like to see a 15-story
memorial to the victims yeah
[Applause]
and someone could drop the ball because
that building is a war memorial that
building was destroyed in the attacks on
on Ground Zero that building should have
been designated a war memorial I mean
somebody dropped the ball so we all have
to pay it's outrageous that should be I
I think that would be a perfect spot I
don't think going underneath I mean I
think it's outrageous
they're hiding it and also is there not
a room there's a room behind a a vaulted
room where they're literally putting how
much sixteen thousand human remains
seven stories
in a museum can you imagine an amazing
programmable element in the museum seven
stories below street level that's where
people that have never received their
loved ones remains will have to go to
visit Rosaline you know a lot about this
911 Memorial Museum just would you you
spoke about it and seem back this is
very important this is something that we
need to fight at the same time it's
wrong and they do and they they do if we
make enough of a cost but we have to
learn from our enemies let's use that
Playbook yeah they know how to pitch a
fit we gotta start pitching it's the
same exact thing tell us what you know
about the um there's a lot I I could
start just by saying they have called
themselves the national 911 Memorial
Museum to give this idea that it has
national landmark status and it's not
it's not under the protection of the um
National National Park Service so
therefore it doesn't get protected in
terms of how signs get displayed and and
all the historical
preservation that goes along with
something like this so it's under the
control really of the politicians and we
know that from Pataki choosing his what
he wanted for Ground Zero
um the initially the names were going to
be um as Pamela alluded to under uh the
waterfalls a way you wouldn't see any
site of what happened in 911 you have
two pools of water with waterfalls
pouring in and I think there's 500 trees
500 trees covering the plaza so there's
no no and there's no signs to say this
is
um the 911 memorial there's we're lucky
if there's one American flag there
that's because we insisted on it and we
insisted the original plan come on yeah
come on Sally
um and we so when we found out where the
names were going to be we decided to
hold this vigil of love and honor in
front of my brother's Firehouse to bring
attention to the fact that the names
were underground then we learned all
about their plans to put the museum onto
the ground up to this point we thought
that there was going to be an above
ground Museum we found out that all the
museum with all the artifacts all the
pictures were is all under street level
so there's nothing on the site that's
going to really bring back any memories
of 911 and and the Real Horror for us as
9 11 cameras we're very lucky my mother
and I we have a cemetery but people like
Sally who never received their loved
one's remains will have to go seven
stories below great and Below street
level
to visit the the remains that are there
and then the real insult is that they're
using it as what they call a
programmable element in the museum where
they're going to have it behind the wall
saying behind the in essence behind this
wall is are the dead so it's a like a
ghoulish descent you go down you see all
the horror of 9 11 and then you're down
with the bodies it's just not the
dignified final resting place in these
remains what we wanted was something it
can to the Tomb of the Unknown Soldier
something like the Tomb of the
unidentified you know above ground
that's ground that that's 9 11.
foreign
wasn't the buildings it's not the
waterfalls it was the people we lost I
have to say that in the early days many
of the families of the victims spent all
their time
speaking to this lmdc this this
organization that no one knows who they
are where they came from this
organization that controlled the future
of Ground Zero we spent all our precious
time
trying to advocate for what the families
of the victims wanted
we received the document from this lmdc
which included the city of New York and
the state of New York and various
entities Port Authority saying that we
would have a separate and distinct
Memorial
like a Tomb of the Unknown Soldier where
the families could come
and visit the remnants of the Dead in a
dignified and private manner
then they totally abandoned that they
did not inform the families and only
recently in the in the past year or two
did we find out that they plan to take
my son's human remains
and the human remains of 40
of all the victims and put them in a
museum that it is an outrage it is an
atrocity
put them in a museum that will
definitely most likely be a paid Museum
yeah for millions of tourists from all
over the world to come put it in the
basement of this Museum seven stories
below grounds it is dangerous it is
dishonorable it is an atrocity and our
rights as parents and relatives of the
victims have been removed this is what
is planned our organization our group
911 parents and families of firefighters
and World Trade Center victims we are
exploring legal
Avenues to stop this from happening it
is an outrage and we need the public we
need people caring and concerned
Americans and people from all over this
world to support us stop this atrocity
foreign
families that got paid off we just can't
get over it we should go home we were
bought and paid this is what the science
people are saying about us and it's a
crime and this is the man there do you
know if the 911 memorial will say
specifically that the Islamic radicals
cause
the latest the latest we've heard is
that there's going to be a corridor a
corridor was it a corridor yeah
um as Sally and Rosaline uh and rosemary
mentioned uh the victim's names of
course are around these pools at street
level now because two of them slept out
there in the middle of winter to call
attention to that
um but what a lot of people aren't aware
of is that there is another Memorial
component within the museum and it's a
series of photographs of all the victims
including Shanksville including the
Pentagon uh they're calling it a river
of faces basically it's just going to be
a mosaic of of individual photographs
top photographs 12 feet off the floor
okay if you're the Unlucky family member
to go there or friend or what have you
your loved one may be at that 12 foot
level if you want to know anything about
that person you've got to go to one of
several kiosks to pull that information
up and yet right adjacent to that area
is what we're calling the Terrace Hall
of Fame basically which is a corridor
which is dedicated to the history of Al
Qaeda and it takes us right through
right through to 911. and what's what's
really of course going to many of us is
the fact that the 19 individual
hijackers are going to be individually
shown at human Heights
individualized and given ordered them
quotes about why they hate America
artifacts and yet the families uh
victims
photographs 12 again 12 feet off the
floor so anyway uh all I can ask for you
is that we do have one website that's
going right now is
www.respect911 excuse me respect you
remains at the World Trade WTC Memorial
um so if you just Google human remains
Memorial you'll find us so read on there
that's about the human remains issue but
there's a whole bunch of other things
that I would just ask that you just keep
pay attention to this because
um the the momentum is there on their
part and uh I guess the only thing last
to mention for Pamela is that she
mentioned earlier that Daisy Khan was
asked to be an advisor to the museum but
the funny thing about it is that
um it was on their website probably
around June or July it was a statement
about it and the quote was something to
the effect of
um that she was being brought on to make
sure that the story of Muslims were
woven throughout the entire Museum
experience
now magically that disappeared in July
or August okay I copied it before it
went off but it disappeared off their
website you can't find it anymore you'll
find references to on other websites I
mean
once it becomes a big deal they don't
make it they don't make it the big deal
trust me trust me on this uh it's up to
you it's up to all of us to email all
this stuff out I will I will post more
about it and you have to send it out and
you have to write your congressman and
you have to make a big deal about it and
then we go back down and we will be back
down
we will be back down I don't know if
they know but on 9 11 on the 10th
anniversary we'll be back down there and
I'll tell you why we're going to be back
down there first of all I used to go to
ground zero every 9 11 after 9 11. and I
couldn't get down to the pit because I'm
not family so you were outside that um
that steel fence and I'm going to tell
you something it was a freak show every
left-wing Auntie Bush anti-war
um 911 truth though it was like it's
such a depressing day that you go down
there just to you know to find Solace
with like-minded people and it was
really doubly depressing because it was
9 11 and so you were Mourning
and you were surrounded by these Kooks
and nobody ever said anything when they
protested every year Pamela Hall she's a
witness we always put we always we
always together
um and then when when when on 9 11
because Daisy Khan did say she was gonna
break ground we were going to have our
protest the ground zero ground ground
zero I got a ton of hell because I'm
being disrespectful I wasn't being
disrespectful that's the way I thought
was we brought tens of thousands of
Patriots down to ground zero on 9 11.
thank you
this year 911 I don't know if you're
aware of it but Durbin anybody know what
Durbin is the racist conference that
incredibly antsy Israel antium they're
going to be in New York oh nice they're
going to be in New York for Durban three
around 9 11. oh no you can't tell me
that is Islamic supremacist conference
is not deliberately choosing Ground Zero
and 911 but for that conference so we
will be back down yeah and there's no
reason why this should not be very much
a part of
the fight because this is really this is
this is outrageous and I tell you people
don't know about it yes
which one there's one that designed this
thing lmdc the lowest
they designed it no they're just in
charge look they were the ones who that
they greenlighted the mosque uh the
landlock status of the mosque the lower
the omdc had the overall responsibility
and all the power in determining
everything that happens at Ground Zero
including uh in moving this design ahead
this uh underground Memorial Museum and
by the way the families of the victims
spent years in useless meetings I don't
know if you've ever heard of listening
to the city we had to go to the Javits
Center we had to go to Pace University
we had to go all over leave our families
spend all our precious time when we
should have been mourning in trying to
assure that we would have at least the
proper memorial for our loved ones they
we we gave in our opinion they threw it
in the garbage can and they picked out
what they wanted bury the bury the
memorial bury the story of 9 11 buried
911. I'd like to tell you to introduce
you this is Rosemary Kane she's another
911 mother of a heroic firefighter
George Kane and you might you have seen
her in the documentary she had she came
down to the community board she
testified
she's one of our our most active mothers
and I'd just like you to say a word
about the design and the Memorial Museum
the museum the whole journey since
September 11th has been just an
eye-opener for me never in my wildest
dreams did I think that nine and a half
years later we the families would have
to be fighting for something that should
be just a given yeah on September 12th
this country was United
everybody was calling the firefighters
in the police department Heroes I didn't
call him a hero he's my son
I just wanted my son back
and we all had to come to grips with the
fact that our loved ones were never
coming back
but we felt good because of the unity
and the American flags and the
patriotism that abounded throughout the
country and little by little it's just
Fallen away the politicians have taken
over they've wiped everything out of the
rug and they have put a gag order on
everything we have done press
conferences we've been down at Ground
Zero we've had so many issues like like
Sally said instead of being able to sit
home and mourn our loved ones and start
a journey in our grief we've been out
facing all these issues
and the politicians no matter who you
talk to be it the media the newspapers
you never see anything about it there's
a gag going out that's why the average
people you guys the citizens throughout
the country we talked about well do you
know that they're uh leaving the remains
in the garbage dump in Staten Island
people are astounded they don't know
about that do they know that they're not
giving the responders their their rank
oh why is that nobody knows about it you
people the regular people in the city
you don't know what's going on because
the media doesn't let you know and
that's a disgrace
we're not asking for anything more than
a respectful remembrance of the victims
of September 11th somebody has the
handle is there a legal gag order is it
just part of the media conspiracy I
think it's just a part of the conspiracy
I think Bloomberg is too powerful yes
and that's a very scary thing to have
one man so indifferent to everybody else
he has so much power he controls
everything
you know what this is very important to
remember
um you need to understand the power of
your vote yeah and you know when we were
at CPAC there was one councilman there
out of how many that voted she was the
only person that stood up for the family
it is so important for you to take the
mantle on your vote and you need to find
out is that the people that are trying
and Vine for positions in the city Mayor
Bloomberg you know this is one now upset
about
um all of a sudden he can't bet the
clergy you know he can't interfere but
he can take salt from the table that I
can't wrinkle on my McDonald's
what if what he wants to interfere with
and this is why it's so important for us
to be on these people day in day out
relentlessly relent that city council
holds the key to many things and we need
to be on them about everything these
three ladies have said we have to be on
this one gentleman from Queen right yeah
Daniel Holloway
the rest of you oh you're on your own
thank you
to reiterate if you if you want to
understand what we're talking about
regarding this horrendous Memorial
so-called Memorial Museum please visit
the website and that's respect human
remains at the 9-1-1
memorial.com you will understand all our
issues are there and you'll understand
why we feel so devastated
hurt wounded it is it is the worst
feeling in the world to have your child
murdered
and then to have somebody else say we're
going to take possession of these
remains and we're going to put them
where we want to put them so we can get
more people to come into this Museum and
pay money so we'll make money on this